buongiorno è parlare di rifiuti prima
ma non è proprio una cosa simpatica
magari ma sono stati
bravi coloro che mi hanno preceduto e
quindi siamo andati nei tempi giusti e
prima cosa cosa c'è nei rifiuti che
produciamo ogni giorno nelle nostre case
nelle nostre attività nel nostro lavoro
prima di tutto ci sono rifiuti organici
rappresentano il 34 per cento del totale
dei rifiuti urbani di cui ci liberiamo
ogni giorno poi abbiamo la carta la
plastica il vetro i tessili i metalli il
legno ed altri rifiuti il 90 per cento
dei rifiuti che produciamo è riciclabile
o recuperabile
non c'è nessuno della mia famiglia in
questa sala altrimenti si emozionerebbe
perché questo signore che vedete sono io
da giovane e avevo cominciato a fare la
raccolta differenziata già tanti anni fa
ne produciamo dei rifiuti urbani ogni
anno circa 30 milioni di tonnellate che
corrispondono a un 58 per cento di
rifiuti che raccogliamo in modo
indifferenziato volgarmente di tali e
quali
e poi invece ad un 42 per cento di
raccolta differenziata
noi siamo messi male rispetto al
contesto europeo ed internazionale
perché in italia raggiungiamo il 42 per
cento del totale dei rifiuti che
produciamo raccolti in modo
differenziato e avviati a recupero
riciclo in germania come in olanda in
francia e nel regno unito sono poco
sopra di noi in francia li battiamo ogni
cittadino europeo produce ogni anno
circa 520 kg di rifiuto urbano negli
stati uniti se ne producono 750 in cina
40 chili all'anno è una stima realizzata
dall international solid waste
association riguarda soltanto le grandi
città cinesi 40 kg abitante contro i
nostri 520 è però in europa siamo poco
meno di 400 milioni di abitanti
i cinesi hanno superato abbondantemente
il miliardo di abitanti
immaginiamo quando continueranno quando
raggiungeranno i livelli di consumo
che invece abbiamo già raggiunto noi
cosa può diventare per il mondo il
pianeta intero il problema dei rifiuti
italia le differenze territoriali sono
molto marcate questo è il paese che noi
siamo abituati a conoscere l'italia è
fatta così dell'italia amministrativa
l'italia politica
questa è l'italia della raccolta
differenziata dei rifiuti
vedete ci sono delle regioni che
raggiungono soprattutto nel nord est del
paese il trentino e il veneto
percentuali superiori al 60 per cento di
raccolta differenziata
poi abbiamo a scendere percentuali
sempre più inferiori fino ad arrivare a
quelle piccolissime purtroppo di alcune
regioni del mezzogiorno sono molto
grandi e molto larghe le sproporzioni
nella raccolta tra le regioni italiane
l'italia vera che dovremmo rappresentare
se parlassimo di questo è quella che
emerge da questa cartina a destra e le
differenze territoriali sono un problema
di educazione
c'è un problema culturale si è anche
vero vedete vietato buttare i rifiuti e
lo diciamo a tanti angoli le nostre
strade ma se girate per le strade di
roma osservando un po qualche lapide che
non è commemorativa agli incroci delle
strade
troverete molto speso est vietato fare
bruttura 300 anni fa 400 anni fa i
cardinali che amministravano la città
invitavano i cittadini a non abbandonare
i rifiuti sono passati secoli ancora
purtroppo assistiamo a scene di questo
tipo poi c'è la creatività in qualche
nostra regione e che dà luogo anche a
questo tipo di risultati e le
esortazioni sono continue e perché chi
abbandona i rifiuti sporca disturba
degrada e compie un'azione
fondamentalmente incivile sul tema
dell'educazione ci sarebbe molto da fare
si fa molta educazione anche nelle
nostre scuole è tuttavia quella che
servirebbe sarebbe molta molta di più
rispetto ad oggi
ma non è soltanto un problema di cultura
non è soltanto prema di educazione di
diffusione delle buone consapevolezza in
materia di tutela dell'ambiente e anche
della salute dei cittadini e del
territorio
in cui viviamo ci sono anche differenze
territoriali importanti per esempio nei
sistemi di raccolta perché raccogliere i
rifiuti con i cassonetti stradali è
molto differente per accoglierlo con le
campane piuttosto che con la raccolta
porta a porta con i centri di raccolta o
le isole ecologiche oppure con i nuovi
ritrovati che si stanno dispiegando con
molta intensità nel nostro paese che
sono le cosiddette stazioni ecologiche
interrate cioè dei cassonetti con le
presse che sono stazionati sotto il
suolo e quindi consentono di mantenere
in condizioni decorose
l'estetica dei luoghi ma nello stesso
tempo di compiere l'azione di accettare
i rifiuti di pressarli e poi li potere
di conferire con molta più facilità sono
sistemi differenti e che fanno sì che
concorrono a modificare anche i
risultati che le aspettative
vedete lara qui il livello di raccolta
differenziata rispetto rispetto ai costi
se abbiamo soltanto il modello di
raccolta differenziata stradale
avremo dei livelli di costi piuttosto
bassi ma anche basse percentuali di
raccolta differenziata quando il sistema
diventa più complesso con i centri di
raccolta le campane alle stazioni
ecologiche interrate i risultati
migliorano diventano eccellenti quando
si passa al sistema di intercettamento
porta a porta cioè si va direttamente
dove il rifiuto viene generato dove il
cittadino l'utente avrà provveduto a
selezionarlo in modo corretto già al
momento del conferimento lo si potrà
asportare e consegnare alla filiera
della selezione della valorizzazione con
molta più facilità
è un sistema che apparentemente sembra
più costoso ma in realtà come vedremo
invece è il sistema virtuoso anche dal
punto di vista economico le differenze
territoriali non sono soltanto sulla
organizzazione dei servizi che vengono
offerti ai cittadini e alle imprese ma
concorrono a fare le differenze molto
spesso anche quelle che sono le filiere
del recupero
in lombardia sono attualmente in
esercizio 58 impianti
di compostaggio sono quegli impianti nei
quali si possono portare i rifiuti
organici gli scarti domestici della
nostra alimentazione per trasformarli in
compost cioè un ammendante di
fertilizzanti chimici che serve per
arricchire il suolo e favorire le
coltivazioni sia del florovivaismo sia
nella sede cultura e sia anche per
impieghi umani quando questo compost e
raggiunge una buona qualità la lombardia
ne ha 58 e quindi quando in lombardia si
raccolgono i rifiuti organici con il
sistema porta a porta piuttosto che il
sistema stradale o con i bidoncini
questi rifiuti vengono consegnati al 58
impianti che li trasformano in compost
in calabria ce ne sono soltanto 5 cioè
sono soltanto cinque spiega questo anche
quella immagine che avevamo visto
qualche minuto fa e cioè di quella
italia che invece sviluppa molto poco la
raccolta differenziata sono cinque in
calabria ma sono quattro nel lazio e 4
in campania tra il 58 e 45 impianti la
differenza è immensa perché accade
perché in realtà l'impiantistica di
smaltimento con la grande larga
disponibilità di discariche che vi è
stata nel corso degli ultimi decenni ha
fatto sì che il sistema di gestione del
ciclo dei rifiuti preferisse le buche
per nascondervi rifiuti e magari
lasciarli alle generazioni future
anziché occuparsi di industrializzare
modernizzare e rendere virtuoso
ambientalmente il sistema in sicilia
ancora oggi nel 2015 il 93 per cento dei
rifiuti urbani e vengono raccolti vanno
in discarica in calabria 71 per cento in
puglia il 67 per cento in veneto e in
friuli e lombardia in emilia romagna
invece le percentuali crollano e
diventano quelle delle armi migliori
performance europea puntare sul riciclo
quindi è sì importante perché dal punto
di vista ambientale è la scelta più
intelligente che si possa fare
pensate che per ogni 10 mila tonnellate
di plastica che si raccolgono in modo
differenziato
si ottengono 100 mila megawattora
risparmiati di energia elettrica ma si
risparmiano anche 12 milioni di
tonnellate di co2 che si evita di
immettere in atmosfera per ogni 10 mila
tonnellate di vetro raccolte in modo
differenziato e avviate al recupero si
risparmiano 10.000 barili di petrolio e
12 milioni 12 mila tonnellate di silicio
che sarebbe invece stato utilizzato se
avessimo prodotto quel vetro da materie
vergine ci sono gli ambienti gli aspetti
ambientali quindi che ci danno la
positiva di risparmiare risorse naturali
e quindi materie prime e nello stesso
tempo ci consentono di evitare il
ricorso alle discariche ma anche ai
termovalorizzatori dei
termovalorizzatori avremo ancora bisogno
per un po di anni fintanto della
raccolta differenziata e la filiera del
recupero e del riciclo di materia non
raggiungerà i livelli che sono
desiderati ma non vi è dubbio non vi è
dubbio che il loro destino è segnato
perché puntare sul riciclo oltre che per
ragioni ambientali anche per altro
perché il mercato delle materie prime e
seconde è uno dei pochi comparti in
crescita dell'economia nazionale pensate
che nel 2014
l'italia è diventato leader europeo del
packaging e cioè dell'industria degli
imballaggi dalle scatole di cartone alle
lattine di alluminio alle bottiglie del
vetro ormai siamo leader europei al
primo posto è l'unico comparto della
manifattura industriale che negli ultimi
sette anni è sempre cresciuto nel 2014
l'incremento rispetto all'anno
precedente del fatturato è stato del più
1,4 mentre tutte le altre industrie
mentre tutti gli altri settori
industriali del nostro paese sono
declinati in questo invece siamo
diventati leader europei ma gli utilizzi
delle materie seconde sono cresciute gli
impieghi che se ne può fare della
plastica riciclata in questo caso per
esempio vi mostriamo una pista ciclabile
e percorsi che sono stati asfaltati con
plastiche riciclate
e tanti altri usi si possono fare ora
questo non è proprio quello più
apprezzabile ma con i rifiuti e le
materie riciclabili si possono fare
tanti altri impieghi nel campo della
bioedilizia nel campo delle bioplastiche
e nel settore dell'abbigliamento pensate
al pyle quel tessuto inventato in italia
e che ha ottenuto dalle fibre del pieti
cioè le bottiglie di plastica nel quale
conserviamo i liquidi dei quali ci
alimentiamo non soltanto acqua ma anche
bibite a è perché puntare sulle ciclo
gli aspetti economici i rifiuti
indifferenziati costano oggi per ogni
tonnellata che noi raccogliamo abbiamo
al trattamento e smalti anno costano 130
euro ogni tonnellata ne produciamo 30
milioni di tonnellate pensate se
dovessimo tratta di tutti come
indifferenziati quale sarebbe in corso e
dovremo sopportare con la raccolta
differenziata invece spendiamo per il
trattamento la selezione fra gli 80 ei
100 euro 50 60 euro tonnellata però di
raccogliamo ricaviamo dalla
valorizzazione cioè dalla vendita di
questi di questi beni il risultato
finale è che il nostro paese potrebbe
risparmiare un miliardo di euro all'anno
si sviluppasse le politiche di raccolta
differenziata e del riciclaggio secondo
gli obiettivi che ci sono stati
prescritti dall'unione europea
da noi condivisi e recepiti nelle
normative del nostro paese nelle aree
strategiche cosa fare
obiettivi chiari e misurabili vincolanti
per tutte le regioni italiane perché
molto spesso accade che la sensibilità
delle amministrazioni locali delle
comunità locali sia poi la leva
fondamentale per azionare e realizzare
gli obiettivi che sono stati prestiti
dalle norme
quando questa sensibilità non c'è allora
vediamo che declinano le percentuali di
raccolta ci si adagia sui sistemi
conosciuti le discariche piuttosto che
altro si spera si pensa di spendere meno
e di fare in modo più efficace ed
efficiente il proprio dovere
cosa che poi invece non è considerato
che il nostro paese in questo momento
sta soffrendo centinaia di infrazioni
dall'unione europea proprio per non aver
smontato in materia di rifiuti ed avere
oggi da bonificare centinaia e centinaia
di discariche sul proprio suolo
promuovere la diffusione delle migliori
pratiche perché siamo leader a livello
mondiale nell'impiantistica per il
riciclaggio e sappiamo progettare
costruire e gestire gli impianti di
compostaggio
ma anche gli impianti per la
rigenerazione della plastica anche le
vetrerie che lavorano il rottame di
vetro possiamo vendere tecnologia
possiamo vendere innovazione possiamo
vendere know how sostenere lo sviluppo
dell'impiantistica il riciclo sia a
valle che a monte con una grande opera
di interesse nazionale come se fosse una
grande opera di interesse nazionale
perché il veneto ricicla sette volte più
della sicilia ci sono fattori
strutturali
il primo è il territorio in veneto noi
abbiamo rispetto alla sicilia un numero
di comuni piccoli molto più largo di
quanto non sia nella regione insulare
questo vuol dire molto perché nei grandi
centri
il controllo sociale il cittadino che
osserva l'altro ai comportamenti
dell'altro e li giudica ed eventualmente
talvolta li sanziona è molto più
efficace che avvenga in un piccolo
villaggio in un piccolo centro in una
piccola cittadina che non è una grande
città in una strada di napoli dove
risiedono 30 mila abitanti in una sola
strada dove risiedono 30 mila abitanti
il controllo sociale molto più difficile
che non in un paese che abbia gli stessi
numeri dello stesso numero di abitanti
però in modo diffuso nelle residenze su
un vasto territorio il controllo sociale
e cioè la partecipazione alla
sensibilità di ciascun singolo cittadino
scoraggia i comportamenti scorretti del
vicino in veneto questo è più facile
rispetto invece a regioni come quelle
che in questo caso abbiamo comparato la
sicilia come quelle che sono più
attardate un secondo fattore è la
cultura industriale perché dove è più
radicato il sistema industriale degli
eco distretti dei network delle reti più
file dove soprattutto c'è manifattura
c'è lavoro
la cultura d'impresa e i risultati anche
in termini di gestione dei rifiuti sono
molto differenti
in questo caso possiamo immaginare che
il veneto tutte le industrie che
producono rifiuti e producono un
materiale che dall'industria accanto può
essere utilizzato per una impresa
quello è un rifiuto per l'impresa vicina
magari è risorsa e materia lavorabile
per altre produzioni
questo è un sistema più circolare
rispetto a quello che invece conosciamo
in tante regioni del mezzogiorno un
terzo fattore è il tessuto politico
sociale inutile negarlo
le minori infiltrazioni dell'illegalità
la minor presenza di criminalità
organizzata fa la differenza un
operatore industriale in campania
piuttosto che in sicilia soffre
certamente condizionamenti che nel
veneto come in lombardia con altre
regioni soffre molto meno quarto aspetto
importante di questa differenza il ruolo
delle municipalizzate
troppo spesso le demonizziamo troppo
spesso pensiamo che siano un fattore di
di sgoverno un problema per la pubblica
amministrazione costose e dove i livelli
di produttività e di efficienza non sono
quelli desiderati
eppure il ruolo delle municipalizzate e
stato fondamentale perché in veneto come
in lombardia come in toscana
queste imprese sono state quelle più
radicate nel territorio vissute dai
cittadini dove ci lavorano cittadini di
quel territorio che hanno potuto
pianificare e programmare a lunga
distanza tutti gli interventi che erano
necessari per la comunità e il progetto
degli accordi stretti
l'idea che a roma ci siamo fatti che sta
diventando forzatamente di valenza
nazionale e cioè che tutti i rifiuti
possono essere consegnati ad
apparecchiature ha stabilimenti in
luoghi nei quali la materia possa
tornare alla materia vale a dire i
luoghi nei quali i rifiuti
entrano e possono essere lavorati per
tornare ad essere invece un prodotto o
finito solo con una dendo top
le prime due crociate che videro
vincenti cristiani nel momento in cui
andarono liberare gerusalemme furono
vinte con un'arma segreta non tutti lo
sanno l'arma segreta erano i rifiuti i
rifiuti perché i crociati si portavano
appresso maiali e con i rifiuti che
trovavano o che era loro alimentazione
nutrivano i maiali e maiali garantivano
quindi alle truppe carne fresca
abbondante disponibile i musulmani non
mangiavano maiale e quindi i loro
eserciti che più numerosi e che
conoscessero il territorio perché benché
ben armati e non erano nutriti nel modo
siamo ovviamente qualche secolo fa non
erano nutriti in quanto lo fossero i
cristiani la terza crociata andata
peggio perché il grande sultano decise
che le truppe in combattimento anche
quelli esami che potevano vincere e
mangiando maiale e io spero che questa
metafora ci aiuti per il futuro i
rifiuti una risorsa una risorsa che
possa contribuire al miglioramento della
qualità della vita di ciascuno di noi è
un momento in cui vengono gestiti i modi
intelligenti e con un po di cultura e
sapendo guardare anche al passato grazie
grazie